The aim, when a filmmaker promotes a film, is to reach the maximum amount of people,...
...so film producers invest astronomical amounts of money in promotional techniques.
They want to capture and maintain the attention of audiences...
...and they go to any lengths to achieve it.
Through these huge promotions, investors hope to recover production costs.
To achieve their ultimate goal of enticing the viewers,...
..."CinemaScope", wide screen projection, and 3D were created.
TV and radio also play an important role.
Product placement, where clippings of films appear during TV shows,...
...and extended placement, where talk shows discuss films and their technical part,...
...are the techniques used.
Another major technique is the virtual world, where you can see trailers of films.
The traditional form of paid advertisement in newspapers and magazines...
...is still a very important part of any campaign.
Co - branding and co - advertising are also used.
The film industry spends more than 2 billion dollars yearly in marketing.
It costs a lot of money to make a film.